.
#fakenews!
... science #fakescience!
Wem der Kampfbegriff Fakenews
zu alt ist, low and behold:
Fakescience!
Es interessiert sich kaum jemand
für die Wissenschaft.
Aber wenn Pharmakonzerne überteuerte
Produkte rechtfertigen möchten,
wenn Scharlatane
Scheinmedizin verticken möchten
oder wenn Politiker nichts
vom Klimawandel hören möchten,
dann brauchen sie?!?
Eigentlich nur gute PR.
Wissenschaftliche Studien.
Für eine gute PR.
Aber nein!
Nicht für alle Behauptungen
gibt es wissenschaftliche Belege.
Und jetzt?
Leiden Sie auch an Studienmangel?
Predatory Journals helfen.
Predatory Journals!
Hinter Predatory Journals
stecken Betrüger,
die sich als wissenschaftliche
Zeitschriften ausgeben,
aber in Wirklichkeit
einfach jeden Scheiß publizieren,
und ich meine wirklich jeden Scheiß,
einfach nur gegen ein bisschen Geld.
Erkaufte "Wissenschaft".
Und das kommt dabei raus:
"Aspirin Plus C" ist eigentlich
nur Aspirin und Vitamin C,
aber wir verkaufen es
einfach mal doppelt so teuer,
und wir haben auch eine Studie,
die sagt, dass es sich lohnt.
Unser Krebsmedikament namens GcMAF
hat zwar real keine Wirkung,
aber wir haben Studien,
die es zeigen.
Warum sind die Menschen so dumm
und glauben
diesen ausgebildeten Klimaforschern,
wenn wir doch diejenigen sind,
mit den Studien,
die sich Menschen
eigenhändig erkauft haben!?!
Doch die True Stories
hören da nicht auf:
Neben Scharlatanen veröffentlich
auch ernsthafte Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler
in diesen Predatory-Scam-Journals!
Aber doch nicht in Deutschland!
In Deutschland rund 5000,
darunter Max-Planck-, Fraunhofer-,
Helmholtz- und Leibniz-Institute
und auch Top-Universitäten
wie die RWTH Aachen.
Diese Skandale wurden aufgedeckt
unter dem #fakescience,
nach monatelanger Recherche von NDR,
WDR und der Süddeutschen Zeitung.
Und bevor ihr jetzt schon ausrastet
und denkt: Was?!?
Dann hört euch mal das an:
Diese Scam-Journals
sind nichts Neues,
und sie sind
in der wissenschaftlichen Community
auch schon seit Jahren bekannt.
Was?!? Aber warum habt ihr
davon noch nie was gehört?
Die Wissenschaft hat's verschwiegen?
Fakescience!
Fakescience! Fakescience!
Nop! Predatory Journals wurden
in der wissenschaftlichen Community
nicht nur offen diskutiert,
sondern sogar erforscht.
Oh! Nur bisher hat es
kein Schwein interessiert!
Es ist
ein ziemlich akademisches Thema,
das aber für jeden von uns
unglaublich relevant ist.
Und dass die aktuellen
Berichterstattungen das Thema
endlich mal in die breite
Öffentlichkeit tragen, feiere ich.
*Tröten*
Aber:
Ich bin ein bisschen sauer
über die Art und Weise
der Berichterstattung
und auch über diesen Hashtag.
Ich komme darauf zurück.
Unter #fakescience
gibt es einige Artikel,
auch Podcasts,
Videos, Fernsehreportagen
das verlinke ich euch alles.
Aber einige Punkte
kamen meiner Meinung nach zu kurz,
und die möchte ich
in diesem Video nachholen.
Weil ich sie
unglaublich wichtig finde.
Also Freunde der Sonne,
macht es euch bequem! Setzt euch!
Dieses Video
wird "maiLab"-Volldröhnung!
*Titelmelodie*
Freunde,
wenn der Trenner so spät kommt,
wisst ihr, ich meine es ernst!
Fangen wir an
mit einer kurzen Einordnung:
Was ist eigentlich
das Ausmaß dieses Problems?
5000 Wissenschaftler*innen in
Deutschland, das sind rund 1,3%.
Wenn man jetzt noch mit einberechnet,
wie viele Paper
jährlich publiziert werden,
dann ist der Anteil, wenn man sich
die einzelnen Publikationen anschaut,
wahrscheinlich im Promillebereich.
Erst mal schön zu hören.
Das Problem ist also
nicht völlig "out of control".
Aber!
Wissenschaft muss
an den allerhöchsten Standards
gemessen werden!
Und dass so etwas überhaupt passiert,
egal wie klein der Anteil ist,
ist eine Schande und inakzeptabel!
Mal im Ernst: Wie kann so etwas
überhaupt passieren?
Seid ihr bereit
für die Abgründe der Wissenschaft?
Freunde der Sonne, seid so gut
und versetzt euch mal kurz
in eine Chemikerin:
Das bist du, eine Chemikerin
in ihrer Doktorarbeit.
Und was ist das Wichtigste
für deine Doktorarbeit?
Äh, dass ich unbekannte Fragen
auf...schlüsseln kann
und die Welt
ein bisschen besser verst...
Nein! Versuch es noch mal.
Dass ich innovative Technologien
entwickeln... ?
Nein! Versuch's noch mal.
Dass die Doktorarbeit
wichtiger Teil meiner Ausbildung ist,
wo ich lern...
Nope! Das Wichtigste ist,
dass du publiziert!
Denn solange
du nichts veröffentlichst,
bist du als Wissenschaftlerin
nichts wert.
Veröffentliche oder verrecke!
C'est la vie!
Was ist das Wichtigste
an deiner Doktorarbeit?
Publizieren!
- There you go!
Dieser Publikationsdruck
ist eine ganz schöne Scheiße!
Nicht falsch verstehen,
es geht nicht um:
"Oh, ich muss
so viele Paper schreiben,
ich muss was leisten, ich komme
mit dem Druck nicht klar. Mimi!"
Nein!
Also, der Druck
ist durchaus sehr belastend
für die Wissenschaftler*innen.
Aber scheiß auf die Wissenschaftler!
- Was?
Nur für diese Argumentation.
Der Publikationsdruck
ist schlecht für die Wissenschaft!
Für die Wissenschaft!
- Nee, schlecht für die Wissenschaft!
Der ist schlecht
für die Wissenschaft.
Warum ist er schlecht?
Weil nur positive Ergebnisse
publiziert werden.
Dabei ist Forschung nun mal
keine Aneinanderreihung
positiver Experimente!
Forschung kann auch heißen,
dass du Wochen, Monate oder Jahre
an etwas forschst,
mit Fleiß, Herzblut und Hirn,
und trotzdem
nichts Brauchbares dabei rumkommt.
Whapabitch, it's how it is.
Wissenschaftliche Durchbrüche sind
nicht nur abhängig von guten Ideen,
Fleiß und Zeit, sondern natürlich ist
auch Zufall, Glück und Pech dabei!
Außerdem ist jede Erkenntnis wichtig,
auch eine negative, z.B.:
Ha! Das hat jetzt
schon mal nicht geklappt.
Oder:
Seltsam... dieses Experiment
widerspricht all meinen anderen.
Wenn das stimmt, muss ich eine
ganz neue Hypothese entwickeln
und meinen ganzen Forschungsplan
umstellen!
Und Schwups, ist
die Doktorarbeit auch schon vorbei!
An manchen Unis bekommst du
deinen Doktortitel erst verliehen,
wenn du z.B. 3 Paper publiziert hast.
Obwohl eigentlich jeder weiß,
dass man positive Ergebnisse
nicht erzwingen kann,
wird genau das
von den Studierenden
und Promovierenden verlangt!
Ihr ahnt vielleicht schon,
worauf das Ganze hinausläuft.
Aber bevor wir weitermachen,
müssen wir noch kurz klären,
wie so ein Publikationsprozess
idealerweise aussieht.
Zurück zu dir, der Chemikerin
oder dem Chemiker.
Du weißt jetzt also:
- Ich muss publizieren.
D.h. du rackerst, du sammelst Daten,
du wertest sie aus,
und - Heureka! - sie ergeben Sinn.
*Tröten*
Du schreibst deine Ergebnisse
in einem Manuskript zusammen
und schickst dieses Manuskript
an ein wissenschaftliches Journal.
Die erste Hürde für den Manuskript
ist die Redakteurin des Journals.
Sie ist nicht unbedingt
Spezialistin deines Fachgebiets,
aber sie checkt schon mal,
ob dein Manuskript Hand und Fuß hat
und ob es zu dem Journal passt.
Dein Manuskript
besteht diese erste Prüfung,
und die Redakteurin schickt es
weiter an 2 bis 3 "Reviewer".
Die sind jetzt Spezialisten
deines Fachgebiets.
Die Reviewer prüfen jetzt, ob
dein Manuskript relevant genug ist,
innovativ genug, ob es Mehrwert hat,
ob alles
wissenschaftlich korrekt ist.
Du wirst nie erfahren,
wer diese Menschen sind,
damit du sie
nicht bequatschen kannst.
Du erhältst daraufhin eine Liste
mit Kommentaren dieser Reviewer.
Die haben vielleicht
noch mal Nachfragen,
evtl. ist was unklar,
du hast mal einen Fehler gemacht,
vielleicht fehlen Daten,
vielleicht musst du auch noch mal ins
Labor und ein Experiment nachholen.
Was auch immer es ist,
du tust das, du korrigiert es,
du schickst es zurück.
Das kann sich
auch noch mal wiederholen.
Jedenfalls,
wenn ganz am Ende alles stimmt,
wird dein Paper publiziert.
*Tröten*
Das war jetzt der einfache Weg.
Es kann auch anders laufen.
Die Reviewer
können dich auch "rejecten".
Weil sie z.B. denken, du musst
noch mindestens ein halbes Jahr
im Labor arbeiten,
bevor du ausreichend Daten hast.
Oder schlimmer:
Sie sehen gar keinen Grund,
warum du das je
publizieren solltest.
Oder du wirst direkt im ersten
Schritt vom Redakteur rejected.
Ihr seht,
es ist nicht so einfach,
so eine Publikation durchzubekommen.
Dieser Kontrollprozess
durch Kollegen, durch "Peers",
wird "Peer Review" genannt.
Freuen wir uns jetzt erst einmal
darüber, dass Qualitätssicherung
bei wissenschaftlichen Studien
großgeschrieben wird!
Aber:
Jetzt erinnern wir uns an...
"publish or perish".
Und spätestens jetzt
sollten wir feststellen, hmm!
Hmmm!
Eine hohe Qualität von Publikationen
und ein hoher Output, ein erzwungen
hoher Output von Publikationen
werden nicht immer vereinbar sein.
Ich wiederhole:
Der Publikationsdruck
schadet der Wissenschaft.
Wie sieht dieser Schaden genau aus?
Im besten Fall kommt es
zur "Salami-Theorie". True Story!
Wo Wissenschaftler*innen,
die gute Arbeit machen,
sich Gedanken machen müssen,
ob sie das Werk als solches lassen
oder ob sie's nicht vielleicht doch
in drei kleinere Paper einteilen,
ohne wissenschaftlichen Grund,
einfach nur, damit
ihre Publikationsliste länger wird.
Wenn ich statt einem Paper
drei Paper draus mache,
darf ich promovieren.
Im weniger guten Fall
kommt es zur Verschwendung von
Steuergeldern und Potenzial,
wenn die Leute anfangen, nur noch
nach low hanging fruits zu greifen.
D.h. uninspiriert, uninnovativ
ihre Forschung
nach Publizierbarkeit auslegen.
Und nicht den interessanten,
großen Fragen nachgehen,
weil die komplizierter sind
und länger dauern.
Im schlimmen Fall
führt das zu Leuten,
die ihre Forschung besser darstellen,
als sie wirklich ist.
Seltsam! Dieses Experiment
widerspricht all meinen anderen.
Es ist einfach nie passiert.
Und im schlimmsten Fall
gibt es überall unehrliche Menschen,
die täuschen und betrügen,
und durch den Publikationsdruck
umso mehr Incentive bekommen.
Kurz gesagt: It's a mess!
Aus dieser Mess
stiegen nun Predatory Journals empor.
Aber es ist nicht ganz so einfach,
wie es scheint.
Denn auch hier geht es leider um...
*Musik: # "money, money, money"*
Will ich ein Paper publizieren,
muss ich als Autorin immer eine
gewisse Gebühr an den Verlag zahlen.
Aber das meiste Geld
machen die wissenschaftlichen Verlage
mit Payrolls.
Wer die Studie lesen will,
muss zahlen.
And that is a little bit fucked up.
Erstens sind Publikationen
ja eben dazu da,
um sie mit den Kolleg*innen
zu teilen.
Damit sich die Wissenschaft,
aufbauend darauf,
weiterentwickeln kann.
Zweitens ist die meiste Forschung
mit öffentlichen Geldern,
also mit Steuergeldern, finanziert.
Und die Steuerzahler
haben keinen Zugriff
auf die Ergebnisse einer Arbeit,
die sie selbst finanzieren.
Und genauso absurd:
Viele Wissenschaftler
haben nach der Veröffentlichung
keinen freien Zugriff mehr
auf ihr eigenes Paper.
(Seufzt:) Zum Glück
habe ich noch das Manuskript.
A little bit fucked up.
2011 gründete
eine Doktorandin aus Kasachstan
die unglaublich
erfolgreiche Schattenbibliothek
Sci-Hub.
Millionen
wissenschaftliche Studien,
die es normalerweise
nur hinter den Payrolls gibt,
werden hier geklaut
und bereitgestellt.
Ist natürlich illegal, und trotzdem
wird es von vielen unterstützt.
Weil man sich natürlich fragen kann,
wieso ein Verlag
überhaupt Gewinn machen darf.
Mit Arbeit,
die von Steuergeldern bezahlt wurde.
Es gibt aber auch eine andere Lösung.
Seit etwa zehn Jahren
gibt es "Open Access Journals".
Das Geschäftsmodell von Open Access:
nicht die Leser zahlen,
sondern die Autoren.
Ist natürlich auch problematisch,
wenn ich als Autorin
Geld dafür zahlen muss,
dass ich nur meine Arbeit mache.
Aber wenigstens ist diese Arbeit
dann jedem frei zugänglich.
Obwohl Open Access
prinzipiell eine gute Idee ist,
bietet es natürlich den Rahmen
für die Predatory Journals.
Deren Geschäftsmodell
ist denkbar einfach:
Der Autor zahlt
und das Journal publiziert.
Es gibt kein Peer Review,
es gibt keine Qualitätskontrolle.
Man erkauft sich eine
"wissenschaftliche" Veröffentlichung.
Es gibt so viele geile Beispiele,
wo Wissenschaftler
demonstriert haben,
wie abartig scamig
diese Journals sind.
Z.B. diese kreative Antwort
auf eine Spam-Mail.
Mit einer Manuskript-Einreichung
namens
"Get me off
your fucking mailing list".
Natürlich wurde dieses Ding, so wie
alles andere, automatisch akzeptiert.
Was aber nicht selten passiert,
ist, dass unerfahrene Studierende
und Promovierende
auf diese Journals reinfallen.
Das wissenschaftliche Äquivalent
zu diesen typischen Scam-E-Mails,
wo dir der nigerianische Prinz
schreibt,
dass er dir 12 Mio. Dollar
vererben möchte.
Man kriegt von denen auch E-Mails.
Nur steht darin dann, dass sie
deine Arbeit veröffentlichen möchten.
Die wollen mein Manuskript!
Das ist besser als Geld.
Jetzt kommt das richtig Dreiste:
Ich bin reingefallen, hab mein
Manuskript aus Versehen eingereicht.
Selbst wenn ich meinen Fehler bemerke
und mein Manuskript
zurückziehen möchte,
wird es wahrscheinlich
trotzdem veröffentlicht.
Notfalls sogar ohne Gebühr.
Das ist natürlich das Beste,
was diesen Predatory Journals
passieren kann.
Dass echte Wissenschaftler ihre echte
Wissenschaft aus Versehen einreichen,
mit der sie sich dann brüsten können.
Predatory Journals
heißen zurecht predatory.
Weil sie buchstäblich
Raubverlage sind,
denen Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler
oft zum Opfer fallen.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht,
wie viele Wissenschaftler Opfer sind
und wie viele betrügen wollten.
Aber schauen wir uns doch mal
die Betrüger genauer an.
Denn hier müssen wir eine extrem
wichtige Differenzierung treffen.
Achtung, Achtung,
extrem wichtige Differenzierung!
Lasst uns nicht alle Menschen,
die absichtlich bei einem
Predatory Journal publizieren,
in nur eine Schublade stecken.
Lasst wenigstens
zwei Schubladen draus machen.
Schublade eins:
Wissenschaftler*innen,
die ihre Publikationsliste
erweitern möchten.
Diese Wissenschaftler
haben null Interesse daran,
dass irgendjemand diese Paper liest.
Und sie haben gute Chancen,
dass sie niemand liest.
Weil diese Schrott-Journals
letztendlich wie der Mülleimer
der Wissenschaft sind.
Und sie werden beten und hoffen,
dass niemand, der sie
irgendwann mal einstellen möchte,
da mal genauer hinschaut.
Menschen, die unehrlich sind,
die betrügen und schummeln,
dürfen keine Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftlerinnen sein.
Aber ihre Schrottpaper
werden keinen aktiven Schaden
anrichten.
Die wird niemand lesen, das ist
einfach nur Ressourcenverschwendung.
Schublade zwei:
Konzerne, Lobbyisten.
Politiker, Aktivisten,
Populisten, Scharlatane.
Ich hab nur eine Schublade,
es geht um alle Nichtwissenschaftler.
In dieser Schublade
besteht kein Publikationsdruck.
Diese Menschen wollen
ihre eigene Agenda durchsetzen.
Mithilfe falscher "Wissenschaft".
Im besten Fall
werden hier Produkte geschönt
für bessere Verkaufszahlen.
Im schlimmsten Fall
kommen Krebskranke zu Schaden,
die glauben, eine neue Therapie
gefunden zu haben.
Diese Paper, die schaden.
Nicht nur der Wissenschaft,
sondern wirklich direkt auch Laien.
Wenn jetzt aber Scharlatane
mit der Hoffnung und Gesundheit
kranker Menschen spielen,
dann sind Predatory Journals
nicht das zentrale Problem.
Sie sind ein Mittel von vielen
zum Zweck,
zu einem abscheulichen Zweck,
der strafrechtlich
verfolgt werden sollte.
Aber was machen wir jetzt
gegen diese Predatory Journals?
Fünf Dinge können wir tun.
Und wer auch immer ihr seid,
die ihr gerade dieses Video schaut,
bei mindestens einer dieser Lösungen
seid ihr persönlich gefragt.
Erstens:
Aufklärung der Wissenschaftler*innen.
Es gibt bereits schriftliche
Guidelines, davon muss es mehr geben.
Genauere, spezifischere,
am besten für jede Fachrichtung.
Natürlich sind alle Wissen-
schaftler*innen sowieso gefragt,
bei allem, was sie tun,
ihr Handeln zu reflektieren
und sich selbst weiterzubilden.
Zweitens: Unis,
Forschungseinrichtungen und Verleger
müssen jeder für sich,
aber auch gemeinsam
schärfere Policys
aufsetzen und durchsetzen.
Außerdem kann man gemeinsam
white lists und black lists
über verschiedene Verleger
oder Journals aufstellen.
Ansätze dazu gibt es schon,
Link in der Videobeschreibung.
Drittens: weg mit der
"publish or perish"-Mentalität.
Wir müssen neu überlegen,
wie man Leistung, Qualität und
Mehrwert wissenschaftlicher Arbeit
sinnvoller evaluieren kann
als über eine Publikationsliste.
Viertens:
guter Wissenschaftsjournalismus.
Für 'ne Expertin ist es leicht,
ein Schrottjournal
aus ihrem Fachgebiet anzuschauen
und sofort zu sehen, das ist Schrott.
Für 'nen Laien
ist es quasi unmöglich.
Deswegen brauchen wir
guten Wissenschaftsjournalismus,
der auch einem gewissen
"publish or perish" widersteht.
Ich sehe auch Schwierigkeiten
in der aktuellen Berichterstattung
über dieses Thema.
Z.B. war ich ein bisschen
enttäuscht über die Reportage,
die am Montag in der ARD lief.
Da hätte ich mir
einen sachlicheren Ton gewünscht.
Ich hätte mir mehr Infos gewünscht.
Generell war ich,
glaub ich, ein bisschen enttäuscht
über die monatelange Recherche.
Weil zumindest für mich
als Wissenschaftlerin
da nicht viel Neues rauskam.
Und wenn man mit dem Rundfunkbeitrag
auf eine Scam-Konferenz
nach New York fliegt,
um dort einen Studenten
zu konfrontieren,
der mit Forschungssteuergeldern
auf eine Scam-Konferenz
nach New York fliegt,
dann ist das ironisch.
Fünftens: öffentlicher Druck.
Hier bin ich sehr dankbar
für die aktuellen
und neuen Berichterstattungen.
Denn sie bringen eine neue Dimension
in die Diskussion.
Nahbare, konkrete Beispiele,
die jedem klarmachen sollten,
dass das hier
kein akademisches Problem ist,
sondern etwas,
das uns alle betrifft.
(Stöhnt:) Ich hoffe wirklich,
dass unter der schärferen Beobachtung
durch die Öffentlichkeit
und vielleicht
durch ein bisschen Druck
die Punkte 1-3,
die ich gerade genannt habe,
endlich mal
ernsthaft angepackt werden.
Ich hab letzte Woche über die Macht
der Zuschauer gesprochen.
Jetzt ist genauso ein Moment,
deshalb war es mir so wichtig,
dass ihr wisst, was los ist.
Damit ihr euch auch
in die öffentliche Diskussion
einmischen könnt, wenn ihr möchtet.
Aber:
Ich finde,
wir brauchen einen neuen Hashtag.
Denn Fakescience
in Anlehnung an Fakenews
lädt nicht zu einer
konstruktiven Diskussion ein.
Ich hab so was von die Schnauze voll
von Fakenews.
Das als Scheinargument
gegen alles verwendet wird,
was einem nicht passt.
Die Art von Debatte hat
bei einem wissenschaftlichen Thema
nichts verloren.
Deshalb hab ich
eine Keks-Frage an euch:
Unter welchem Hashtag
könnte man dieses ganze Problem
konstruktiver diskutieren?
#realscience wäre mein Vorschlag.
Wenn ihr Vorschläge habt,
kriegt ihr von mir ein Keks-Emoji.
schreibt sie in die Kommentare
und koppelt sie bitte an #real,
damit ich sie auch leichter finde.
Ich hab heute, ungelogen heute,
etwas in der Post bekommen.
Und das machen wir mal
in der Endcard auf.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Jetzt nicht fallen lassen.
Oh Mann, das ist echt... crazy.
Alter! Uuh!
Freunde der Sonne!
Danke. Da steht "maiLab".
Freunde der Sonne, ich werde mich
für zwei Wochen verabschieden.
Denn wir machen
eine kleine Sommerpause.
Ich sollte das, was ich gerade
über "publish or perish" gesagt habe,
auch auf diesem Kanal ernst nehmen.
Qualität vor Quantität, deshalb
gönne ich mir eine Verschnaufpause.
Ich komm dann in zwei Wochen wieder.
Volle Kanne am 16. August.
Und bis dahin...
bleibt sicher!
Ich freu mich auf eure Kommentare.
Und danke!